we American
okay okay what kind of American are
you John says have you seen the trailer
for the new Civil War film and what is
your opinion on it so I had not seen it
and then when we were running through
the show this morning uh we took a look
at it I'm going to throw it to it right
now so this is going to be in theaters I
guess in the next couple weeks right
theater it's going to be in theaters few
months in a couple months um but it's
getting a lot of Buzz online right now
so I thought we'd watch it together and
then we can commentates have seceded the
United States Army ramps up activity the
White House issued warnings to the
Western forces as well as the Florida
Alliance the three term president
assures the uprising will be dealt with
swiftly let me know if you want to try
anything on are you guys aware there's
like a pretty huge civil war going on
all across America we just try to stay
out with what we see on the news seems
like it's for the
best citizens of America the so-called
Western forces of Texas and
California have suffered a very great
defeat at the hands of the United States
military Mr President do you regret the
use of air strikes against American
citizens we moving to DC today we need
to go down there they shoot journalists
on site in the capital every Instinct in
he says this this is death
blood but here we are there's some kind
of misunderstanding here what we
American
okay okay what kind of American are
you you don't
know the Western forces will reach the
White House on July 4th oh God in the
car get in the
car God Bless
America all right so that's only my
second time watching it I'm sure first
time for many of you guys uh there's a
lot of interesting stuff there I would
say basically you know I like futuristic
kind of dystopian couple years from now
kind of movies uh there is a feeling in
this country that there's a lot of
weirdness between red and blue and
everything else so something seems kind
of cool about it uh there is a chilling
to it there's there's a warning there's
an uncomfortability there for sure I
would say uh the idea that the Western
forces of Texas and California I mean
I'm pretty sure if we end up in a civil
war situation Texas and California are
going to be on the wrong are going to be
on opposite sides of things right we're
going to have like a Florida Texas
alliance with some other red States
basically with New York somehow and Cali
together and it's just going to be a
geographic mess and all that hopefully
we do not go down that path although you
know me I am for the states doing
whatever is right for the states and for
the citizens of those States um there is
something kind of I would say it's kind
of chilling in the I would also say that
you know Hollywood creates a lot of crap
although when you say a24 as a studio
it's Banger they make bang they make
bangers that means they make good films
told uh so I guess we shall
see